martin biron madeleine blé m'aurait
bonsoir alors tant à ottawa qu'à qu'au
québec il ya eu des appels à la prudence
par les autorités sanitaires
c'est très clair on va écouter si vous
le voulez bien monsieur legault qui
comme vous savez est allé se faire
vacciner aujourd'hui au stade olympique
il a eu le vaccin phison on ne l'a pas
mentionné tout à l'heure et alors lui
dit oui et ça manque mais il faut
regarder les hospitalisations comme au
début de la semaine on ne voyait pas
d'augmentation et mais on envoyait une
actuellement
ce qu'on veut c'est qu'elle soit la
moins grande possible puis la plus
courte possible
pour l'instant on reste en bottes 500
hospitalisations donc aucune
augmentation du nombre
d'hospitalisations
mais on s'attend à ce qu'à ce qu'ils en
aient une au cours des prochains jours
l'heure on voit le début d'une troisième
bac
si les québécois suive pas les consignes
il ya un risque d'une grosse vague
si on suit les consignes on va rester
ce contrôle
cet intéressant martin parce que là on
voit peut-être mieux que jamais la
distinction entre la décision politique
d'un dirigeant politique ce soit en
ontario québec par rapport à la science
qui appelle demande une plus grande
prudence actuellement peut-être si on
avait le choix un retour en arrière
comme sur le goût d'y écouter ça
marcherait pas de toute façon mais c'est
tellement ça et c'est comme ça depuis le
début de la semaine même
mardi on s'attendait à ce que monsieur
legault envoie des signaux un petit peu
plus fréquentes
certainement pas qu'ils permettent aux
étudiants de secondaire 3 4 5 d'aller à
l'école tous les jours en zone rouge
des signaux qu'on avait de la science
avant des gens qu'on entend souvent sur
nos ondes
c'était qu'il fallait resserrer tout de
suite après cette conférence de presse
la conférence de presse de monsieur
legault il était quand même assez
détendu par rapport à la situation
ces mêmes scientifiques là on en rajoute
et aujourd'hui la pression monte mais
l'objectif du gouvernement toujours été
le même protéger le système de santé
c'est à dire tant que les
hospitalisations sont relativement
convenable citant que sélectif c'est
faisable
on va regarder la situation comme elle
est et surtout éviter les décès alors en
bottes 500 monsieur legault semblait
quand même encore à trouver a estimé que
les choses étaient sous contrôle ont
marqué qu'une question d'adhésion en ai
vu un gars l'américaine s'est excusé
pour qui est revenu sur cette décision
de confinés pendant la période de pâques
à monsieur legault est au même endroit
il voit que les gens sont tannés macron
qui jongle avec sa confinement pas
confinement un pas en avant deux pas en
arrière
il ya la réalité aussi madeleine parce
que les autorités à ottawa sanitaires
ont dit aujourd'hui on demande enfin on
conseille aux provinces est extrêmement
prudent de ne pas de confiner du strict
point de vue scientifique quand on
regarde la lala bébé andy sommet c'est
plus compliqué à gérer
là parce que la bibitte n'est pas là
même qu'elle était au début de la
première vague
c'est une bibitte qui a varié qui
accueillirent changé et qui est
maintenant plus contagieuse on parle
d'un taux de contamination qui est plus
élevé quand on parle des airs la
contamination par exemple 100 personnes
vont en contaminer en ce moment 120 130
autres qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire que la cour va repartir à la
hausse
ça veut dire que si on ne fait rien de
plus
on va en vivre une troisième vague à
quel point elle va être intense cette
vague là c'est beaucoup trop tôt pour le
dire mais martin a parlé d'un mot qui
est fort important et c'est le mot
adhésion parce qu en faire plus ça veut
pas nécessairement dire avoir de
nouvelles mesures si la population les
suit pas ces mesures là elles vont être
totalement inefficace avant d essayer
finalement de réduire les contacts
comment on les réduit est ce que c'est
pas des campagnes de publicité est ce
que c'est en disant aux gens finalement
faites attention ce variant l'oeil est
beaucoup plus dangereux ou est ce que
c'est en faisant marche arrière
ça c'est au c'est effectivement les
décisions très très délicate que les
autorités doivent prendre les dirigeants
doivent prendre et doivent prendre le
pouls de la population pour savoir
qu'est ce qui va fonctionner le mieux
mais en ce moment ce que je vous dirais
c'est que la santé publique nous dit ce
qui se passe en ce moment ça fonctionne
pas bien
voilà exactement on multiplie parce que
docteur de serre par exemple est quand
même allé assez loin aujourd'hui martin
en disant on conseille de d'une plus
grande prudence de resserrer un peu
autrement dit mais je vous montre les
chiffres du québec sont prêts à mener
les chefs du québec monsieur legault
s'accroche à la ligne effectivement vous
l'avait bien dit des hospitalisations en
dha est encore une baise de 15
on est à 480 on était à presque 1600 il
ya quelques semaines donc il en est de
l'espace pour manoeuvrer je peux pas
toujours fermé maintenant ouais mais bon
premièrement vaccine davantage les
personnes âgées commençait à ses
protégés mais le week-end
votre critique et puis bon c'est une
phrase qu'on entend souvent la semaine
voire critique là mais là on n'est qu'en
mai la croisée des chemins et l'autre
les vaccins et les variants et à
surveiller la semaine prochaine le point
de presse de mardi
peut-être qu'il va vouloir encadrer
davantage suivi quelques consignes
peut-être pour une semaine ou deux on
est vraiment à cheval entre la paix et
le désastre et là-dessus quelque chose
d'encourageant c'est que la campagne de
vaccination va pouvoir s'accélérer quand
on parle de la course variant contre
vaccin on va recevoir d'ici les trois
prochaines semaines
autant de vaccins qu'on en a reçu durant
les trois derniers mois donc on va
recevoir 6 millions de doses d'ici le 18
avril si je ne m'abuse
ça va permettre de finalement accéléré
enfin la cadence de vaccination en fait
on l'a accéléré depuis un certain temps
l'homme est allé encore plus à fond la
caisse ça c'est vraiment le nerf de la
guerre
la vaccination alors vous parlez martin
demar dit monsieur legault a parlé de
pâques
alors ça c'est l'autre en fin de semaine
passée le silo on écoute on y connait
c'est certain ça nous inquiète
et la parole chrétienne et la pâque
juive parce que c'est une occasion de se
rassembler ya un risque et associée à
part ça sent bien c'est pas le bon
moment donc un peu comme on l'a vécu
avec le congé scolaire est un test à
passer pour la pub chrétienne et juive
donc moi ce que je demande c'est de
suivre les consignes
si on suit les consignes on va être
carré
donc pas de rassemblement puis ça nous
rappelle tellement l'an dernier papa de
rassemblement autour du jambon a pas que
martin ça vient de tomber
on va on convoque les chefs syndicaux
mardi soir à québec
ouais c'est la collègue véronique prince
qui a eu cette information là où
effectivement sonia lebel va rencontrer
la présidente du conseil du trésor les
six ce chef des syndicats mardi soir
pour déposer une troisième offre c dans
l'air on veut que ça bouge peu ces négos
là ça fait presque non je pense que la
convention collective est échue de
l'ensemble des employés de l'état et je
pense que monsieur legault aimerait que
les conventions collectives soit réglée
en même temps que la pandémie c'est à
dire que tout ce qui est un peu
compliquer le tout les petits cailloux
qu'il a dans son soulier
il aimerait bien les extirper pour le
printemps pour qu'on puisse passer à
autre chose à la relance économique
à partir de l'automne prochain alors je
sens que ça va bouger là en fait le
gouvernement vous bouger les choses le
dernier droit qui souvent on rappelle
qu'il ya quoi 550 mille employés du
secteur public ça touche pas mal de
monde
ouais 550 milles puis rappelez vous que
député l'année dernière la conclusion
comme enseigne négocier il y avait des
surplus débordant dans les coffres de
l'état et là il ya eu 2 et là ça
commence à être un petit peu plus
difficile mais les syndicats avaient
l'impression que c'était leur tour alors
là on le présente au conseil du trésor
à ce moment-là 7 et christian dubé il ya
eu de la difficulté à négocier là c'est
sonia lebel qui entrent en jeu très bien
madeleine qu'est-ce qu'on surveille dans
les prochains jours dont la température
à baisser la température électorale un
peu il ya le budget le 19 avril sont le
dit alors il semble que entre on sent
moins de d'énervement disent ils à
chaque fois qu'on a des revers côté
pandémie en direct d'un coup et on prend
un peu de recul côté les fronts oui
douche froide quand on parle de
troisième vague est ce que le gouver
en nommant trudeau serait vraiment bien
avisés de convoquer des canadiens pour
aller aux urnes
on va avoir la finalement samedi matin
demain matin les résultats électoraux de
terre-neuve et ça fait des semaines
qu'on parle de ça donc on va les avoir
demain matin ses résultats électoraux là
ça démontre à quel point dans la
pandémie certaines choses peuvent
complètement changé de direction très
rapidement donc imaginez si justin
trudeau se diriger un scrutin en
élections et tout d'un coup on était
face à une résurgence des cas et
pourrait peut-être en subir les
contrecoups politique de cette décision
là donc il va falloir qu'ils mesurent
toutes ces questions là qu'est ce qui
s'en vient pour les prochains jours on
rentre dans une pause parlementaire on
est nous dans un creux de vague je vous
dirai dans les nouvelles
on a eu une semaine de fou hier de très
très très occupé mais moi j'ai une bonne
journée hier
grosse journée avec la cour suprême avec
finalement la vérificatrice générale
la semaine prochaine c'est plus calme
alors l'opposition et c'est de s'en
servir pour prendre un peu plus de place
c'est très difficile de se faire
entendre pour l'opposition en temps de
pandémie
la semaine prochaine ils veulent
convoquer des témoins dans différents
comités parlementaires sur deux aspects
encore une fois la crise de huy charity
donc l'organisation unis ils veulent
revenir avec ça en convoquant des
témoins et l'autre communiqué comité
parlementaire c'est sur toute la sphère
des comportements inappropriés au sein
de la défense nationale
donc c'est pas certain du tout que le
gouvernement va vouloir que du personnel
politique témoigner en comité
donc on s'attend un petit peu
d'affrontements à ce sujet la semaine
très bien pu bon ben martin on le dit
dépôt d'offres en fait dépôt d'offre
discussions finales pour dépôt depuis
autre chose sur votre à darwin
ben écoute et on va surveiller lankais
du coroner avant sur les décès dans les
chu celle des qui reprend au début de la
semaine c'est le chcd privé non
conventionnés 2
et moulins à terrebonne où la moitié des
résidants ont été contaminés par l'aco
vide et le corps des résidents est
décédé de la coved
alors on va commencer à apprendre pas
mal de choses sur ce qui s'est passé
lors de la première vague dans les
sièges c'est une bonne fin de semaine à
vous dire merci beaucoup pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit